Consciousness Freeville as often
misunderstood because we know what they
reference,
but it's difficult to know what by
content,
what we really mean by free will.
A lot of people will immediately feel
that freewill is related to whether the
university is deterministic or
probabilistic and about physics has some
ideas about that which change every now
and then.
It's not part of our experience and I
don't think it makes a difference.
If the universe forces you randomly to
do things or deterministically.
The important thing seems to meet that
in Freeville you are responsible for
your actions and responsibilities is
social interface.
For instance,
if I am told that if I do x,
I go to prison and this changes my
decision to whether or not to do x,
I'm obviously responsible for my
decision because it wasn't a spiel to my
responsibility in some sense or
likewise,
if I do a certain thing that it causes
harm to other people and they don't want
that harm to happen,
that influences my decision.
This is a just course of decision making
that we,
I would call,
it's a free vote decision.
We'll list the representation that my
nervous system at any level of its
functioning has raised a motive to an
intention.
It has committed to a particular kind of
goal.
Let's get integrated into the story of
myself,
this protocol that I experience of as
myself and as well,
and that was what I experienced as well
as it will decision and this decision is
free and in as much as this decision can
be influenced by this course.
So to me for evil is a social notion.
It means that this interface also have
social interaction of discourse of
thinking about things,
about this interface of knowledge,
language,
conceptual thought as relevant for that.
A decision if you a decision in which it
doesn't play a role for instance because
you already addicted to something and
you cannot stop doing it even if you
want to.
Then this decision I would say is not
free.
I grew up in eastern Germany,
it was communist,
eastern Germany and it was a very weird
ideology of the country,
a country that believed in stories about
how the world works.
That I as a nerd thought,
obviously not quite true.
I had difficulty believing the official
stories about how the world works.
It was like some weird kind of religion.
And then the wall came down and it
didn't surprise me in the least.
And then we entered a new dream,
a new shared,
a model of the world.
It was not quite true.
And I realized that most people now fall
for this new model.
It was very interesting for to see if
it's for me.
And um,
if you look for instance,
at the u s the majority of us Americans
do not believe in the theory of
evolution.
Despite all the evidence to the
contrary.
Uh,
the majority of people are on this
planet are religious,
even though that doesn't seem to be very
good evidence for a multitude of Creator
Gods and so on,
in my view,
at least.
And if it existed,
if a creator God exists,
it would be very hard for me to why this
creator,
God really does care about whether I
worship it or,
um,
all these things that we attribute to
create God's fire religion.
So it's,
it's very hard for me in some sense to
intuitively understand why humans are
religious invite humans are ideological.
But I think now over the years,
um,
that this is not a bug.
It's a feature.
Humans are a programmable species.
Religions and ideologies are operating
systems for societies and they have been
so throughout most of our history and
this idea that we can build society
based on rational arguments is very,
very recent and very novel.
And it's not entirely clear if it really
works,
but it's clear that we cannot really
build societies on conflicting
ideologies that are at war with each
other.
In the past that has led to situations
where the ideology solve the problems by
killing the unbelievers or their
religions did the same thing.
And we all agree this is not what you
want to have.
We want to have an open society,
pluralistic society and nonviolent
tolerance society,
but still one where people work together
and cooperate.
That and this ability to wake up into a
shared dream in which people believe
things because their neighbors believe
them has been a very powerful feature.
That's probably the reason vive,
you were able to build our scale
societies.
We have to understand that when people
cooperate,
they're very often in what we call a
prisoner's dilemma,
a situation.
And in order to achieve the greatest
good,
you have to give up something for
yourself,
even as in a situation where that is in
some sense a bit irrational.
Because if everybody else is not doing
it,
you're going to be worse off.
And for these prisoners,
Sal,
I must be,
have various solutions.
The easiest solution is to have a
reputation system.
You basically keep track of who did what
when,
and you make sure that only the good
guys,
uh,
get cookies in the future.
And the problem is that these reputation
systems do not scale.
If you have too many people in your
tribe or your family or in your village,
you just lose track of who did what
when.
And you cannot really synchronize it by
our talking about it.
So after a couple of hundred
individuals,
the reputation system doesn't work very
well.
It also doesn't really work if you are
not looking.
So if nobody is doing this surveillance,
um,
how do you make sure that nobody is
affecting and stealing stuff from the
fridge of your tribe?
Right?
So,
um,
what do we do?
We evolve the ability to be normative.
The ability or the need to be good and
this need to be good.
This need to follow internalized norms.
This need to serve sacred principles is
something that is probably a feature
that is ingrained into our genetic
makeup.
And of course this alone would not be
good enough because goodness is like an
arbitrary vector and value space.
People also have a need to synchronize
what's good.
So people will try to feel what's good
in their ingroup.
It works by empathy is the primary mode
in which we transmit norms.
If you dress up somebody as an
authority,
as a priest,
as a professor,
as a pop star is a politician and this
person says a certain thing was
conviction and people see that,
others believe it,
they start leaving it themselves.
And it's obviously very useful to do
this.
There's almost never a situation where
it's useful to have an opinion that is
different from the opinion of your boss.
So this is the ability that we got.
And it means that people perform the
same things that they have followed the
same rules regardless of the size of the
group.
And this makes it possible to build
agricultural societies.
There's hundreds of thousands of
individuals and then millions of
individuals.
It makes it possible that this
agricultural society has people that
specialized on different fruits and
different traits and different materials
and different crafts and so on and
produce all the multitude of tasks and
tools that we need to get an
agricultural society to run and be able
to outcompete the nomadic societies.
And I think the reason by Homo Sapians
is the only hominid species that's left
us because we out competed them all.
We were in the same competitive niche
and be various species that was
programmable.
There was able to coordinate arbitrary
logical,
buff individuals.
That was very powerful.
It just turns out that this mode of
tribal organization is not sufficient
for the world that we live in now.
Mm.